primera jornada de negociaciones
ambientales tras la cumbre de líderes
mundiales en esta esperada code 26 con
los últimos anuncios de reducción de
emisiones hechos en la cumbre estaríamos
encaminados a una subida del 19 grados a
finales de siglo algo que se alinea con
el límite máximo que la ciencia nos
recomienda el día estuvo dedicado a las
finanzas un tema clave para que los
países con menos recursos económicos
puedan hacer frente a una costosa
transición a economías y sociedades no
basadas en combustibles fósiles y así
contribuir a mantener el aumento de las
temperaturas por debajo del grado y
medio celsius algo que está implementado
en el acuerdo de parís la promesa de
recaudar 100 mil millones de dólares al
año en 2020 se ha quedado corta y la
cifra no se alcanzaría hasta el 2023 una
cantidad que comparada con el gasto
anual que se hace en defensa parece
ridícula el mundo invirtió en 2020 2
billones de dólares sin embargo el
dinero mínimo necesario para transición
a una economía basada en energías
limpias sería una cuarta parte de esta
cantidad y los beneficios superarían los
26 billones dólares ha habido críticas
por parte de la sociedad civil a la
falta de detalles en cuanto a estos
planes de inversión financiera anuncios
del sector privado ha habido empresas
que representan el 40 por ciento de los
activos económicos del mundo que se
comprometieron a invertir millones de
dólares en los próximos 10 años para
acelerar la adopción de una economía
verde y por otro lado ha habido 20
países que dijeron que no invertirán en
proyectos de extracción fósil en lugares
extranjeros y que reconducirán todo ese
dinero a energías limpias ese dinero
representaría unos 8 mil millones de
dólares al año